one more game except a random challenge
might play one we're after this who
knows but again like when I scream for
so long my eyes get tired so I think
this is good time for mindful yeah I
could buy chats goodbye world
let's have I ever wept after losing a
game yeah
many times when I was younger it would
be more more dramatic when I'm older
trying weep on the inside but ok let's
go sound and by world let's be let's be
aggressive fine England GABA time I
haven't played one of these in a while
my opponents already perplexed it looks
like a free pawn III III well that's so
solid
how do I actually do this let's play
i unban full done move to cuz I want to
like make a dynamic position I guess
I'll keep the tension c4 interesting
Osen then I can play my deficit we have
a good night's tango before they should
be more he's some kind of nights tengo
52 you know things upon 94 coming
he takes d4 Knight takes d4 yeah the
problem is the Bishop blocks the Queen
from defending d4 3 and then 3 we could
trade f3 check I'll Castle
Queen takes f3 short castle a3 don't
play rook laborer he ate Ruby a check
King d1 Wow
I think Bishop Bishop e2 is more
expected than play d5 Knight takes d5
Wow I was ready for a takes before and I
was gonna say oh no my bishop when I was
gonna play Bishop g4 but now if I play
Bishop g4
maybe it still works this is so weird
Bishop g4 I could be plundering
everything that at the same time I could
be winning a queen
Knight takes f6 check yeah King HP gh8
Queen takes g4 okay this better be mates
Queen d2 maintain checkmate
was a word this is a really weird
sequence I sacked I sucked so much stuff
Wow a bishop was attacks for a while
yeah no I was ready to turn off the
sound when I played d5
I was waiting for this this move so I
could play this but their Knight takes
d5 it's just a whole mess and amazingly
I think Bishop g4 still just wins the
Queen I can't take with the pawn cuz I'm
queen takes with check I take with Queen
again Queen takes bikini chains I'm
still attacking the Queen Ally for the
mating threat well the game it was a
cool game maybe I'll put that on YouTube
need more YouTube contents people on
YouTube thanks for watching you can
watch live in the past or maybe in the
future and you can like and subscribe